come on it's in the same glass as well
it's contaminated with the [ __ ]
that you bought wine and sucking chris
made me down this
disgusting abomination that is the
finest this is
i bet this is the carlsberg of saggy
like
i bet this is if you don't know
carlsberg is a [ __ ] god-awful beer
um they're awful have you have you
noticed that in japan sometimes they'll
have carsberg or carling and they'll be
like
foreign beer and i'm like no no no no no
i know that's that's
dirt water yeah basically
you know and you're like no no no i know
what this is yeah
this is the good stuff this is [ __ ] off
is this the good stuff the [ __ ] is that
but then again right like again like as
we were saying
connor's not a sake drinker in the same
way that he's not a whiskey drinker well
you've got wine now so
i used to be i used to watch white wine
from yamanashi you know when i first
came to japan i
desperately wanted to be that guy who
was like i love everything japan i'm i'm
a connoisseur of japan
i'm obsessed with sake press x to doubt
he was never [ __ ] like that
no that was like i can't believe he just
looked at my face
when i wasn't with you when i go to a
bar that's what drink do you want to be
like
circuit of course oh yeah where every
time he wasn't with us
yeah of course because because i knew
that you would call me out on that [ __ ]
if i go to a bar and i'm like
but then when connor's there's just like
middle of light please yeah yeah yeah
actually like with you guys i'm like
beer please but like because i don't
want to be called out like
if if i'm with like everyone right and
everyone orders beer and one person
who's
on their first vacation to japan goes of
a sake actually
i'd be like [ __ ] off [ __ ] off you're
just getting too into the
japan atmosphere but it but it tastes
like
[ __ ] there's a reason
there's a reason why a bottle of sake
never costs more than twenty dollars
here's the thing i've noticed very
quickly about sake that i noticed about
just
regular wine is that i [ __ ] hate sake
normally
but if i have it with a good meal and
like a meal that
fits the sake i disagree then i [ __ ]
love it we've had no meal though
yeah that's why it took me a little
longer than usual
what's what got me to like wine was
having my first red wine with a knife
okay to be honest to be honest wine goes
fantastically with meals i agree it's
not
it's not a sake no it's no it's not
wine isn't too strong where like it's
overpowering sake
is like when you when you have your
steak whatever and you have a sake it's
like
great now i've just [ __ ] who the [ __ ]
drinks sake with their steak
what do you eat it with it's usually
fish all right you have fish right
whatever the [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
same thing there's a reason why they
serve
a lot of sake at like sushi restaurants
yeah but when you have it you have this
[ __ ]
changing debate and i just like you have
the debate chris
help me out here chris chris because
this is what happens when we talk about
food on the podcast okay
we always have the most heated debates
about food like whenever whenever food's
brought up we turn into a bunch of
[ __ ] apes i swear to god
like when people drink like hard liquor
with a meal or something i'm like
you have you're immediately just like
absolutely bombing your mouth is not a
hard liquor it's a wine
it's it's like 20 it's 20 so is wine
chris what are your opinion as the
adjudicator of this argument help me
get me out of here viewers dude red wine
is 15 to 20 percent sake
20 name a 20 wine joey you think i'm a
[ __ ] wine sommelier there is no wine
that is 20
that is i've never seen that i've i have
seen that there's probably a wine that
happens
i like i much prefer wine over sake
um i feel like 12 to 15
is the perfect zone anything above that
starts to get like tastes like vodka
right and sake
18 but that still tastes like a hard
alcohol
right no it doesn't burn did you lie it
doesn't bother you
wait did that burn for you yes eighteen
percent yeah eighty percent
like chris said that's not voc is thirty
seven point five yeah but the thing is
i can't distinguish the difference
between that and vodka that is why you
fail what are you on
no no what's wrong with you i'm not i
know i was partly on your side until you
you had the audacity to say that but
someone who
loves food so between vodka and wine no
what i think is that that is strong
enough where it's in the same category
as a vodka taste
no no vodka makes me want to die more
100 but sake does still have the same
kind of quality of like i drink it i'm
like
immediately um whereas the wine i'm like
i drink it and i'm like
oh i can't believe what i'm hearing oh
[ __ ] off we get it you're japanese okay
you're a family don't eat some [ __ ]
whales man
listen they both taste like [ __ ] i mean
i'm not gonna [ __ ] down i love how
this
i love how we've gotten two hours into
this so we absolutely we just drank a
[ __ ] ton of sake
unwillingly and now it's a mess of a
podcast thank you chris
i think if you watch this episode with a
bit of a bit of sucking some chicken
broccoli yeah
okay your least favorite alcohol is it
all on the same level because anything
above
20 percent is the [ __ ] same to you
then honestly
anything of like in like vodka tequila
whiskey
okay gin actually like i actually like
this this man contradicts himself i want
i want to be like phoenix right right
now
being like there is a contradiction in
your statements
actually tastes nice now i'm not saying
that no no i'm not saying that because
i'm british and that that's
that's our cultural expert are we
talking like just gin on its own or like
a gin and tonic
issue and tonic okay gin and tonic
who name one person who drinks drinks
gin [ __ ] gin straight
no no one exactly because you don't hear
like when you have vodka and coke what
do you think i think depressing
university days like i'm desperate to
get drunk yeah right chris
yeah exactly ever where's the last time
when was the last time you had a vodka
and coke chris
i i've vodka tonic like every week are
you okay chris are you okay
no i'm depressed i've established this
by now
okay a whiskey a whiskey you have
straight right you never like okay
whiskey and coke sounds like an
abomination right i
think it's great whiskey and coke's all
right but i mean like i
i rarely drink whiskey whiskey is more
of a mood setter whiskey is there
for like yeah you don't you don't want
to get drunk on whiskey no no no
i like i if people who get drunk on
whiskey are drinking whiskey way too
fast
like kind of a drink that you just kind
of like it warms you up but either way i
don't care for it right
it's like a night cap yeah basically we
all know the superior drink is an
espresso
martini gentlemen right no that's that's
because your body
is just addicted to caffeine i am i am
this boy drinks like
[ __ ] no no no christmas coffee eight
cups of coffee
every day get that wine down here go on
let's try the wine it's tainted with
sake cup now
you put it in the same disgusting cup
for the people you'd be a terrible
sommelier
no no well this wine i'll be a terrible
a
i would not be a terrible somalian i'm
gonna get that out there right now
jordan how is it pronounced there we go
well that was closer to my pronunciation
yeah that's closer to my pronunciation
you didn't know you said
somalian somalia somalians watching this
a frog thing right now oh my god come on
it's like they noticed us
we have a resident french man who
sounded closer to my pronunciation than
yours
what are you on i will fight this battle
to the death
i'm known for being stubborn and i won't
quit